ein menschheitstraum dinge einfach so
verschwinden zu lassen unsichtbar zu
machen so unglaublich jetzt klingt das
ganze ist jetzt wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler aus kreta und wien
gelungen und zwar mit einem ziemlich
cleveren trick ihre tarnkappe arbeitet
mit einer art unsichtbar strahl und
funktioniert in der theorie durch
punktgenaue gegen strahlung wie genau
diese tarnkappe funktioniert jetzt in
klicks und science fiction herzlich
willkommen die meisten von euch kennen
sicher den tarnmantel aus den harry
potter geschichten eigentlich zu schön
um wahr zu sein einfach so verschwinden
wenn man an einem ort ist wo man
eigentlich nicht sein sollte klingt
völlig abgefahren und nach
science-fiction pur aber nein tarnmantel
und tarnkappen funktionieren zumindest
im labor bisher allerdings in dem linsen
ganz speziell angeordnet werden oder
durch exotische metamaterialien diese
leiten das licht um ein objekt so dass
es verschwunden scheint dastan material
hat dabei eine spezielle struktur die
kleiner als die wellenlänge des lichts
ist seine strahlung wird dadurch
abgelenkt und verlässt haben kappe somit
wieder so als sei es nie mit dem objekt
das getan werden soll in verbindung
gekommen
für den betrachter ist das objekt somit
unsichtbar jetzt hat ein forschungsteam
aus kreta und wien eine völlig neue
tarnkappen technik entwickelt bei dem
man weder spezielle linsen noch
metamaterialien braucht das einzige was
benötigt wird ist ein zusätzlicher
lichtstrahl nach angaben der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
soll dieser mit einem ganz bestimmten
wellenmuster das undurchsichtige
material bestrahlen so dass es für einen
zweiten lichtstrahl unsichtbar wird
stefan rotter einer der beteiligten
forscher von der tu wien komplexe
materialien wird wie etwa ein stück
würfelzucker sind undurchsichtig weil
die lichtwellen in ihnen unzählige male
abgelenkt und gestreut werden das licht
kann zwar eindringen und irgendwo wieder
herauskommt aber die lichtwelle kann
sich nicht gradlinig durch das medium
hindurch bewegen stattdessen wird sie
chaotisch in alle richtungen gestoppt
und genau diese wellen streuung stellt
forschungsteams weltweit vor eine große
aufgabe bislang konnten sie diese nur
durch metamaterialien überlisten oder
aber durch objekte die selbst licht
abstrahlen ein beispiel hierfür ein
bildschirm erscheint aus einem
bestimmten winkel tatsächlich unsichtbar
wenn er nach vorne genau das licht
aussendet dass er auf seiner rückseite
absorbiert die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler aus kreta hatten sich
jetzt zum ziel gesetzt den lichtstrahl
auf geraden und auf direktem weg durch
das objekt hindurch zu leiten quasi so
als sei es selbst gar nicht da die
lösung für diese idee seine spezielle
wellen technologie sagt der leiter der
forschungsgruppe constantino markus das
wellenmuster gleicht die material
brechung ausstrahlt waren exakt das
punktgenau muster der inneren
unregelmäßigkeiten auf das material so
lässt sich die streuung praktisch
ausschalten ein senkrecht verlaufende
lichtstrahl gelangt nur mit verlustfrei
durch das material dabei ist eine sache
entscheiden dem material muss punktgenau
energie zugeführt werden an anderen
stellen muss absorption möglich sein
heißt also von oben muss genau das
richtige punkt muster auf das material
bestrahlt werden dass zu den inneren
unregelmäßigkeiten des materials passt
denn dieses würde ansonsten nicht
streuen doch so wird die streuung
vermieden und ein lichtstrahl der dazu
senkrecht verläuft kann ungehindert und
verlustfrei durch das material gelangen
und dieses konzept geht nicht nur bei
licht strahlung auf sondern funktioniert
auch bei anderen welpen zum beispiel
wenn wichtig ist dabei nur dass jedes
objekt mit einem eigenen individuellen
punkt muster bestrahlt wird eben mit dem
das zu seiner mikroskopischen streuung
in seinem inneren passt das
forschungsteam aus kreta und wien hat
praktischerweise gleich eine methode
entwickelt mit der das jeweils passende
punkt muster identifiziert werden kann
in computersimulationen und modellen
funktioniert die neue tarnkappe
einwandfrei jetzt geht es in einem
nächsten schritt darum das ganze
technisch umzusetzen das projekt steht
also noch am anfang hat aber absolut das
potenzial in zukunft den bereich der
planung zu revolutionieren wenn es
soweit ist dann erfahrt ihr es natürlich
hier
wenn er dazu und auch zu allen anderen
themen kein video verpassen wollt dann
drückt mir hier ein aber aufs auge und
vergessen ich den
denn auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr
über die neuen videos informiert hier
geht es weiter mit unsichtbar werden da
geht es um eine weitere tarnkappen
technik also nicht verpassen und
draufklicken und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt